I want to talk about a genius idea to end
the corona virus pandemic.
OK, this is not a new idea.
Donald Trump had this idea some months ago,
but he's revitalizing it.
Here's the idea.
OK, we want to get rid of all cases.
Ready for this?
Stop testing.
Don't do a single test.
We won't find a single case.
This is the idea that Donald Trump, again,
is suggesting proposing.
He said this yesterday during one of those
lame propaganda roundtable events, he was
asked about the reality that the United States
is still finding 20000 or more new corona
virus cases today.
States are reopening some states very unsafely,
Arizona, Florida, Texas, North Carolina, California.
These states are having more and more and
more cases almost every single day.
Trump's about to hold a huge rally in Oklahoma.
Well, what if we just stop testing?
Take a look.
You just have to see it to believe it.
As I said this morning, that's probably the
downside of having good testing as you find
a lot of cases at other countries who don't
even test, don't have if you don't test, you
don't have any cases.
If we step testing right now would have very
few cases, if any.
But we do we're at a level that Mike is going
to talk about that's so high.
But we will show more more cases when other
countries have far more cases than we do,
then just don't talk about it.
So there's actually so much to discuss here.
And it's it's kind of a good opportunity to
do a little bit of a reset in terms of where
we are nationally with coronavirus right now.
So first of all, remember, testing more will
find more cases that that's true.
Generally speaking, but testing more over
the long run reduces the spread because as
more people become aware that they have the
disease, they stay home if they're normal
people and they don't give it to other people.
So get in.
In a sense, if you don't do any tests, you
don't find any cases.
But in terms of the real spread, the more
testing you do, the better you mitigate the
spread of Corona virus.
By the way, we're still not testing five hundred
thousand people a day on average a couple
times in the last 10 days.
We hit this number five hundred thousand tests
today.
We've been talking about needing to be at
a minimum of five hundred thousand a day for
three months at this point.
We're still not there.
OK.
So reminder, we still are not testing enough.
Then Trump continues to insist that we test
so much, we test more than anybody.
The U.S. is currently 20 eigth in testing
globally.
This is per capita testing.
This is a really important detail about testing,
because one of the reasons a couple of months
ago, we were like forty fifth in testing.
Now we're 28.
One of the reasons that we've inched up to
twenty eighth in testing is that there are
countries that no longer need to test because
they've eradicated the virus.
Imagine that like for example, South Korea.
We talked about South Korea's early testing
program.
Now the United States is testing more than
South Korea.
Why?
Because South Korea only ever got to 12000
total cases.
South Korea only ever had 278 deaths total.
The entire pandemic in South Korea was 278
deaths.
So, of course, we're now testing more than
South Korea.
They don't really have a coronavirus pandemic.
Secondly, there are other indicators about
how the virus is going.
Even if you don't test so you could suppress
testing numbers like Trump is talking about
for some period of time.
But you have hospitalizations, you have ICU
usage, and eventually cases turn to death.
So even if you don't test, eventually the
truth get out.
It's like saying if Trump doesn't get himself
tested for an S TDR, he won't test positive
for an S TDE.
Well, that's true.
But eventually things are gonna start looking
a little bit wrong.
If you understand what.
Saying now it's true that it's harder to find
the hospitalization numbers.
Most national dashboard's include cases and
deaths, not hospitalization.
So you've got to dig a little bit more.
But the data is there.
One other really bizarre moment from this
roundtable.
Trump was asked about hydroxy chloroquine
being taken off of the FDA as emergency use
list.
It was taken off because it's not working.
And Donald Trump is very irresponsibly promoted
it for a long time.
Trump said when he was asked about this.
Well, there were good reports about hydroxy
from other countries.
But then he sort of got irritated with his
own secretary of Health and Human Services,
Alex Azar, and turned to Alex Azar and said,
why don't we have some of these good reports,
Alex?
Take a look.
Great reports coming out of France, coming
out of Spain, coming out of other places.
The only place we don't get necessarily reports
are coming out of Alex's agency or wherever
they come from.
I don't understand that, Alex.
What is it exactly?
Because I have heard I have had so many people
that were so thrilled with the results from
Hydroxy.
So what is that exactly what your direction.
We continue to study especially an earlier
phase.
So a lot of the data that has come out of
that was more negative was people who were
quite ill in the hospital, people that were
like seriously ill, like they weren't going
to make it.
Let's give them a little hydroxy and then
then I'll make it.
They say, oh, well, maybe the president was
wrong.
All I know is that we've had some tremendous
reports.
I've had a lot of people tell me that they
think could save their lives.
You know, the one woman who's a fit.
So this is just great insight into Donald
Trump's lack of understanding of how medical
research works, what randomized controlled
trials are, what it means to have a placebo
group.
And and so on and so forth.
Double-Blind how you actually test something
empirically and arguably even worse is that
people around Trump, like Alex Azar, continue
to play Kate Trump and pretend like, well,
you know, yes, some of those tests were on
very sick people, but we should really be
looking into hydroxy chloroquine on people
who aren't so sick yet, prophylactic use.
They just keep placating Trump endlessly.
Now, one more thing to prepare you for the
coming wave of propaganda.
The Trump administration is already floating.
Blame Mexico in terms of some of these states
now having spikes.
Are southern states that share a border with
Mexico, Arizona, Texas, for example?
So they're floating.
Blame Mexico for the spikes.
No evidence of that, by the way, that Mexico
is responsible, combined with blame protesters,
even though a lot of the states that had the
bigger protests are places that are not seeing
a spike.
The protesters mostly wearing masks.
Whereas in places like Arizona and Texas,
things are open.
Almost nobody's wearing masks.
And that's really what we should be looking
at.
So just to prepare you for the coming propaganda
wave, make sure you're following The David
Pakman Show on Instagram at David Pakman,
showed her more on testing and cases and Trump
isms that continue to plague the country.